hi I'm Greg I'm jetting away I'm a tire
cook hey you guys have seen Game of
Thrones right
yeah well Season seven long walk
official promo we'll look at the votes
12,000 votes and only 79 down votes
that's insane
why it's gaming throne no I know but
still it's just like that those are good
number yet it's not like one of our
YouTube videos a lot of people requested
this since the draw today with the first
one that came in Kiera gray Game of
Thrones Season 7 teaser carriage right
she sounds hot she sounds really sexy
ready guys I'm sure this teasers gonna
reveal so much
Smith
more more fat out I have the accent
[Music]
[Music]
I'll walk you to the pan
[Music]
are you ice queen
jacket it's telling I walk Vidia
[Laughter]
July 16th it's halfway to your birthday
well half of the days Chris you know
yeah mom's birthday's annual July okay
whatever
fifteen days away from your birthday
it's early birthday present all watch
this with you good teacher a good teaser
like some sort of epic 1980 TV video
recently yeah right I was kind of
confused because there's so many names
to keep up with in Game of Thrones that
black one season six ended and then it
revealed who Jon Snow really is yeah I
got chills at the same time I was like I
don't know why was he hitting me I'll
tell you the borders and know that
because of all three of us a charge the
only one that's read all the books
you've read all the books that I've been
released oh my god I'm not going to say
I can do I can do another video say this
okay to be fair though it's been a while
since I've read them all but I do love
the series and I am a bit of a nerd and
I love fantasies when it comes to
fantasy novels I'm like I want to read
them all so you know who's going to take
over the Iron Throne no I don't because
books haven't even got that far
so has caught up and to pass the books
so right now I'm with all of you I have
absolutely no idea what's going to
happen that's a great way to end this
show ya know what do you want to take
over this around who do you want to win
at the end oh geez that's a tough one I
I really love Daenerys obviously girl
power all the way I think she's she's a
really great Queen she trusts me more as
a Cersei type I think I think the nurse
and Johnston we're gonna get married
oh right in the true Targaryen event
yeah that's right cuz that this is an
incessant I'm like that's not a problem
dan throws they're totally cool well
that's exactly what they that's exactly
what the whole family is that that's the
whole line is based on incest right
they'll show together yeah that's not
the album family with
if you know Jon Snow or Daenerys were to
gain power I think they'd both be really
good monarchs for the southern kingdoms
and at the last second Theriot takes
over yeah that would be cool
that'd be okay yeah that's a lot of wine
and everyone drops dead except for him
all right well I'm hoping that in the
end Chong snow does take over the throne
because he deserves it the most I think
the Starks deserve it I think Jon Snow
deserves it what is it what is it a
nurse deserve it yeah because she's got
a good track record come on a slave
anything America has taught us as women
can't run things for what just
commanding dragons and a mermaid no I'm
sorry that's all sorry you said Daenerys
and Jon are gonna get married I did yeah
I'm gonna go with that one I think
they're both gonna run it together I so
John so doesn't die in the end because
maybe you can come back to life again no
yeah I think it's really I think is
rather his sister's gonna get killed
redheaded sister oh yeah yeah I think
she's gonna get killed
she's basically in line to be queen if
Jon Snow wouldn't the war right so yeah
I get killed off so Jon Snow can marry
Daenerys okay I mean to be fair she died
it's no great loss oh wow love is
everyone's favorite yeah I'm gonna like
her more and more well she had a long
journey from the start where she was
this whiny stupid girly girl now she's
turning into more of a player
I still remember friends I still
remember when she was like RER you're
ruining every fitting this was like our
shut up [ __ ] but now I like her I think
she's awesome
boy I think that if it shows you to give
us any sort of payoff Jon Snow will
definitely be the king of the Iron
Throne with Daenerys Teen Queen because
the Starks need some respect and power
and David dict over this entire show
from the start of the only good people
in this universe and they keep
constantly getting [ __ ] over our is
going to come back with her family salsa
will be there it's not going to be a
trillion wins arts in a resurrection
a talking hat what do you think is going
to happen to the relative which because
she's cast out out she'll die or shall
worst yet not been killed and so I feel
like she should come back or she might
make a comeback either in this season or
the next I just don't know how I'll be
back yeah yeah I think she's still going
to want to play yeah she still wants to
keep coaching oh my god Jon Snow back
saying I know it's Jon Snow who's going
to be the one right yeah yeah she also
said that about another guy and I [ __ ]
up so I know but that's the only she's
right around when when God talks to you
sometimes there's a miscommunication
when you're looking into science and you
know I don't know I do that maybe it's
that other dude yeah okay well my last
question you guys and is it about the
previous season would you have cast her
out if you were Jon Snow yeah really
yeah Rock Jon Snow back yeah but he has
to do the right thing I mean not kill
her but cast her out is this most fair
conclusion and I want to wanted her
around and he has to do the right thing
and y'all just nose constantly being put
in the position to make the hardest
decision oh I would have put her in like
some kind of cottage off site somewhere
where I could just keep her on lockdown
for a little bit and just in case [ __ ]
goes awry and you know you can go back
again like a video game I want to be Jon
Snow for Halloween this year so I'm
around my hair out again but she wanted
a knuckle man no that was a joke
chomps knows the real life is if I'm
gonna grill my hair app is my hair's
curly he's gotta find the right hair
product to make my hair really Falls
that it poof out I can help you with
that
Thank You Achara curry my favorite thing
about Game of Thrones is a never someone
calls jon snow a bastard child yeah they
all say it the same they're always like
go busting child busted sort of necks or
they okay they can be having the most
casual conversation oh he's Jon Snow
he's a bastard Sonny or even under bust
like a person such to be a bachelor
there's so many hazards in this world
everyone's having sex with horizontally
yeah there's a lot of bastards keep in
mind that every time you're doing a
British accent you're doing it next to
someone who's a British layest so if yo
Jimmy all we know Little Debbie do not
go smoke with toy yeah right yeah you
went too far that's really good Carrie
pool too good yeah subscribe to the real
reject hey hey youtube.com slash Jenny
to Jaffe tube is where he does American
trailer actions and reviews and movie
reviews and then on jab Iike way the
main channel is where he does
international trailer reactions and
reviews and movie reviews like Japanese
stuff and Korean stuff sorry I was going
to sneeze don't you dare Shara Kirk is a
charter Kirk online she's popular there
ya go her her photos and her tweets
where she tweets about life he's in the
bathroom and stuff hmm I love the ballet
I she does and shoutout to Sean Bean
he'll miss you his wife he's watching
your YouTube video oh yeah not being
delicious huge reaction fan